[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] سأجعل
[موسيقى]
جميع الأسباب التي تجعلني أحب المجيء
لزيارة البساطة والعقلية الإجماعية ،
ومن
المحتمل أن تكون المعقولية هي كل الأسباب التي تجعلني لا
أرغب في العيش هنا في بعض الأحيان ، فأنت
تريد فقط الحصول على  حجة جيدة تفقد
أعصابك خرق القواعد
[موسيقى]
لأولئك الذين يمردون في كوبنهاغن ،
هناك ملجأ
كريستيانا هو المكان
الذي تبحث فيه عني وأنا
أبحث عنك ،
كل شيء أكثر متعة عندما تكون
على عجلات ،
لذا  سأستعير لك دراجتي الجميلة ،
أوه ، أوه ،
مرحبًا صباحًا ،
لأنني سأصبح
هذا الشيء فجأة ، فماذا تفعل
مثل مالكها
والبلدية التي تعيش فيها هذه
الدراجة لديها روح خاصة بها ،
لقد
بدأ كريستيانو لأول مرة  عندما استولت مجموعة من
الهيبيين على قاعدة عسكرية سابقة في
أوائل السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
كان طموحها الطوباوي مجرد
إنشاء بلدية بلدة حرة في
وسط المدينة بعد
50 عامًا وما زالت مستمرة
منذ متى وأنت تعيش في المسيحية
منذ 78.
واو 43  نعم  يجب أن تكون تقريبًا واحدًا من
الأصول الأصلية ، لقد كنت جميعًا مخالفين
للقواعد لتبدأ بها ، وما زلنا
غالبًا ما تئن كريستيانيا ليست
الثورة ، فقد كان
هناك تمرد في السابق
بطريقة معقولة ومعقولة ،
على سبيل المثال قاعدة الكتابة على الجدران التي
تسألها لنفسك
هل يمكنني أن أفعل هذا بشكل أفضل
إذا كانت الإجابة لا ، فلن
تفرط في الرسم ،
أليس هذا بالأحرى مجتمع
اليوم الشخصي يحتفل بالتفكير
الحر وليس
الكثير من العلامات التجارية
لكريستيانا وتجارة القنب الشهيرة
في زقاق الدافع
حيث يعني التقدير أنني  زرتها ولكنها
لم تصور
[موسيقى]
تريدني تانيا أن أرى كريستيانيا اليوم
لإثبات أن الناس ما زالوا يعيشون
حياة مشتركة في
المنزل ،
منزل جميل ،
منزلها ملون بشكل رائع تمامًا
كما ستحمله
[تصفيق]
في  هذا البلد من الحكايات الخيالية مرة
أخرى ، صعدت على السجادة السحرية
والأشياء تأخذ منعطفًا غريبًا ولذيذًا
ماذا تفعل
أنا ذاهب لأرى أين البجع
هل أنت مجنون
في عالم فيل  مع مثل التيار السائد ،
إنه حقًا شيء أن تكون على
طبيعتك وأنا أعلم أنني سيدة القمر الأكثر جنونًا
ولكن
هذا الجانب محبوب ، هذا الجانب يتسامح مع
هذا الجانب يدفع هذا الجانب يعترف
بالدنماركية تمامًا